the old town center of Oaks garlotte's
is glorious past and the late Middle
Ages two major trade routes intersected
here tourist guy Gabriella wolf knows
all about the city's history
dammit Bahia Teva find a kite cause
that's feeling Howard lots of merchants
probably passed through girl its trade
and commerce made the city very rich in
the medieval period and that's reflected
in the architecture of the old city
informed the aphorism there are plenty
of splendid gothic Renaissance and
Baroque buildings they form a truly
spectacular ensemble
the ornamentation and detailing are
fabulous arches span a number of the
alleys in the old town these arches are
not bridges you can't walk on them
they're there to stabilize the buildings
to the left and right and look the Sun
is out so cancel your trip to Italy is
just as lovely here all that's missing
is the laundry hanging from the windows
the facade of this Renaissance house is
decorated with reliefs depicting scenes
from the old and the New Testament it is
known as the Bible House an anonymous
benefactor is given the city about half
a million euros each year since 1995 to
pay for architectural restoration da
vindictive isn't very often Soviet zone
we don't know whom to thank so plaques
indicate which buildings have been
restored with the donors help and of
course we aim to be nice to all our
visitors because you just never know do
the benefactor threatened to stop paying
unless efforts to identify her or him
were halted garlotte's wants UNESCO to
recognize it as a World Heritage Site
one reason would be the 35 distinctive
hall houses with vaults stretching
across their wide and spacious entrance
halls the Town Hall boasts this
elegantly curving staircase and a statue
of justice the Town Hall's tower has two
clocks one of them is adorned with the
face of a soldier Jesus are thought and
comma my soldier opens his eyes and
mouth once a minute if we wait for him
to do it now you'll see just how long a
minute is a minuite da watan
this 500 year old doorway fascinates
visitors if you whisper on one side of
the arch what you say can be heard on
the other
but these two won't tell us what their
secret is the foundation stone of the
Church of st. Peter and st. Paul was
laid in 14:23 this is the famous son
organ
it is actually less than 20 years old
but is a recreation of the original from
the early 18th century it is adorned
with 18 golden suns
visiting girl it's is like going back in
time it is no wonder that the city is a
great location for shooting historical
movies lots of stars have come to
gerlichs
convinced they fought off Quentin
Tarantino vada Kate Winslet was here and
Quentin Tarantino and where it's live
Troy just have a look on the internet
for girly wood thank you for taking the
tour with me and enjoy the city